Are you a glass half full or half empty kind
of person?
I’m gonna go ahead and guess half full,
especially if you’re a chimp.
Hey everyone Julia here for DNews.
Have you ever scrolled through a streaming
website site, searching for the perfect movie
and just can’t choose?
Do you just give up?
You’re not alone- too many options seems
overwhelming to us.
A study published in the Journal of Personality
and Social Psychology over ten years ago put
this idea to the test.
You might know it as the famous “Paradox
of Choice” study.
Researchers set up two situations.
One in which people chose from 6 varieties
of jam and the other from 24.
The larger display got more attention, but
only a tenth of the amount of purchases.
The researchers conclude that too many options
turned off shoppers.
The cost of making a decision grows with each
new option.
With more choice comes more anxiety and regret.
What if I make the wrong choice?
They felt too overwhelmed.
So in a world full of too many choices, how
do retailers get you to choose their option?
Manipulation…
I mean marketing.
By framing one option that’s relatively
equal to all the others in a positive light,
we’re more likely to just go with it.
Maybe just to make the anxiety STOP.
Research shows that presenting the same information
in a positive frame yields better results
than negatively framing it.
And it seems there’s not much you can do
about your susceptibility to it.
It might be in your DNA.
All things being equal people prefer a hopeful
spin.
We like to think of our glasses as half full.
This is called “framing”.
Humans above and beyond positive framing.
They will choose the 75% lean steak rather
than the 25% fat one.
Even though they’re exactly the same.
Researchers used to think this was a result
of human culture, something to do with our
society.
But it turns our nearest primate relatives,
chimpanzees and bonobos like to look on the
bright side too.
Researchers framed food options for both our
nearest relatives, bonobos and chimps.
To “frame” in chimp language, they gave
them the option to chose a handful of nuts
or fruit.
In one trial the researchers framed the fruit
option positively by showing a smaller handful
but sometimes giving an extra piece.
In another trial, the fruit was framed negatively,
sometimes they were shown a larger handful
but then actually received less.
The chips had a preference for the option
framed as a prize, rather than an option framed
as a penalty, even when both options were
pretty much equal.
The researchers say this suggests that a positive
framing bias has more basis in our DNA than
in our culture.
So with that in mind, we’ve got 2 videos
down here (point) for you to watch.
This one is okay, but you’re going to be
blown away by this one.
You should click it.
Go on, click it.
While you’re at it hit those like and subscribe
buttons and keep back here for more DNews
every day of the week.